لذلك تركت وظيفتك مع Google جزئيًا
لأنك تقول أنك تريد التركيز فقط
على مخاوفك بشأن الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي تحدثت عنه
قائلاً إن الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن أن يتلاعب أو
ربما يكتشف طريقة لقتل البشر
كيف يمكن أن يقتل البشر
جيدًا في النهاية إذا كان  يصبح أكثر
ذكاءً منا ، سيكون جيدًا جدًا في
التلاعب لأنه سيكون قد
تعلم ذلك منا وهناك
أمثلة قليلة جدًا على
شيء أكثر ذكاءً يتحكم فيه
شيء أقل ذكاءً وهو يعرف
كيفية البرمجة لذلك "  سنكتشف طرقًا
للتغلب على
القيود التي نضعها عليه ، وسوف
يكتشف طرقًا للتلاعب بالناس
ليفعلوا ما يريدون ، فماذا نفعل نحن
فقط نحتاج إلى سحب
القابس عليه الآن هل نحتاج إلى وضعه
المزيد من القيود و و و
آه الدعم حول هذا كيف نحل
هذه المشكلة ،
ليس من الواضح بالنسبة لي أنه يمكننا حل
هذه المشكلة
أم أنني أعتقد أنه يجب علينا بذل جهد كبير
في التفكير في طرق لحل
المشكلة ليس لدي  الحل في
الوقت الحالي ، أريد فقط أن يدرك الناس
أن هذه مشكلة خطيرة حقًا
ويجب أن نفكر فيها
بجد لا أعتقد أنه يمكننا إيقاف
التقدم ، لم أوقع العريضة التي تقول إنه
يجب علينا التوقف عن العمل  الذكاء الاصطناعي
لأنه إذا أوقف الناس في أمريكا الناس
في الصين ، فلن يكون من الصعب للغاية
التحقق مما إذا كان الناس يفعلون ذلك